arlon pour terminer peut-être du congrès
du front national qui va se tenir dans
quelques semaines marine le pen a choisi
de placer la question de la rénovation
du parti et notamment de la question du
nom du parti au centre des débats
est-ce que c'est pas un peu une façon de
détourner injustement l'attention des
militants l'attention des débats de la
question cruciale de la personne de
l'incarnation de la tête du parti par
marine le pen
non parce que je crois que parlons du
nom et non de on n'est pas du tout dans
le déni ont fait 35 % des voix un score
historique aux présidentielles 11
millions d'électeurs qui attendait cela
je crois que mélenchon et fillon aurait
rêvé d'être à notre place bon on fait ce
score il nous en manque encore pour
gagner le pouvoir
donc on se pose la question comment
faire demain comment adapter notre outil
comment adapter notre programme est ce
que notre nom pose problème pour faire
des alliances on pose tout sur la table
ont fait pas l'économie ne voulait pas à
la question la personne va coûter oui
puisque marine le pen est candidate à sa
réélection et que chez nous 16 chez nous
on vote un marvel que chez mélenchon
schéma qu'on ne savait pas de vote ça
dégringole du ciel etc
chez nous les adhérents votent c'est
très facile en plus d'être candidat à la
présidence donc elle elle remet en
question sa ligne elle a proposé aux
militants sa personne en tant que
présidente elle a proposé aux militants
et il y aura un vote on ne fait pas
cette économie on aurait pu dans le déni
comme certains autres certains autres
après l'élection présidentielle
non on a fait le canal à rené jti mais
si je puis dire mais a besoin d'être re
légitimer on a besoin d'aborder la suite
autrement on veut rassembler et on veut
gouverner
comment fait donc marine 2022 c'est
aujourd'hui la blanc seul existe
aujourd'hui plus bas ce sera le mot de
la fin merci sébastien chenu d'avoir été
l'invité de parlement hebdo
merci 4 ça merci c'est un chalut merci
jim